-Our next guest is
a talented actress you know from
"Mission: Impossible -- Fallout"
and "Rogue Nation"
as well as films
like "Doctor Sleep"
and "The Greatest Showman."
She stars in "Dune,"
which is now in theaters
and IMAX and on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-You know the ancient tongues.
-I know many things.
I know that you have a weapon
concealed in your bodice.
If you mean to harm me,
I must warn you,
whatever you're hiding,
it won't be enough.
-The weapon is meant as a gift.
If you are truly the one.
♪♪
Do you know this?
-It's a crysknife.
♪♪
-Do you know its meaning?
-Please welcome to the show
Rebecca Ferguson.
How are you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, I'm good.
-We're so happy
to have you here.
Congratulations on the film.
Also announced today,
there's going to be a sequel.
So that is great news as well.
-I just found out.
-Yeah.
-Are you putting that
on your media?
I mean, I am.
-Oh, absolutely.
We're going to make
a big deal out of it.
And with that sequel money,
you can really splurge on
Halloween candy.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, that's what I'm doing.
Big costume.
-I know you have children.
Where do you get -- You're
a world traveler, as it were.
Where do you get to celebrate
Halloween this year?
-Well, we're thinking COVID
safety -- backyard.
No, we're not. I mean, we are --
We're going to go knocking
door to door.
I think it's more for me and
my husband more than my child.
But we want to dress up
as something scary.
She's thinking unicorn.
So we'll see where we end up.
-Oh, this is very interesting.
The child doesn't want scary,
but as parents you think
she should be more frightening?
-Well, you know,
we need to kind of
get her slowly
into the scary world
because life isn't easy.
Do you know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
-Do you guys dress up as well?
-I mean, not on Halloween,
but other days.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
As evidenced by the clip
we just showed. I think.
-Exactly. Well done.
-I think that there is going to
be maybe a fair share
of "Dune" costumes this year.
Have you considered that?
-I've already had people call me
and say they want to dress up.
So I'm trying to gather
all my costume,
but now I'm going to have to
send it back due to the second.
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
You need it again.
-I shouldn't have stolen
those things.
-Your father is Swedish,
your mother is British.
And this seems very on the nose.
But when you were young,
your mother taught you
how to play bridge,
which seems like just
the most stereotypical
British mother thing
I've ever heard.
-I mean, she didn't teach me
how to play bridge.
She decided to sign me up
to a bridge...
[ Laughs ]
To a bridge course with me
and three other ladies.
I was 15.
They were 85, 80.
[ Laughter ]
And that is not to be ageist.
I had fun, but I think
I was a counter.
You know, I could count cards
very quickly,
so I got kicked out
of the group.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
I did not realize
it's against the rules
to count cards in bridge.
-I just think you have to play
your cards right,
if you know what I mean.
Ruth was not happy.
[ Laughter ]
-Of course, there is always
a Ruth who is not happy.
-[ Laughs ]
-Are you a family
that plays games
together with your children?
-Yes. We do.
My mom actually established
cards.
So when I was young,
she would wake me up at --
I mean an hour before school.
We lived [audio drop]
to the school where I went.
But she put on classical music
in the background.
And it sounds really romantic
and wonderful.
She put Mozart on or something,
and then we'd play
three rounds of cards.
It would be canasta, two-man's
whist, and something else --
gin rummy or something.
But then I had to guess
the music in the background.
She'd go, "Darling, darling,
what are we listening to now?
Darling?"
And then I had to literally go,
"Oh, God damn it.
Handel, Chopin, Mozart?
I don't know."
Just kind of wing it.
But it was --
I do the same without the music
now with my kids, yeah.
-Your mom probably did it to you
to distract you
from counting the cards.
[ Laughter ]
-Well done.
That's exactly it.
Well done.
I hadn't thought of that.
[ Laughter ]
-Your son is a bit older,
maybe old enough to watch a film
like "Dune" or
the "Mission: Impossible" films.
Does he watch your work and does
he think it's pretty cool
the kind of films his mom is in?
-Yeah, I mean, he does.
He's also -- not to forget --
he was, I think, six years old
when I did the first "Mission."
Five and a half, six.
So he was a set baby.
I mean, when I rocked up
into the stunt team,
he would be strapped up
in a harness.
And they basically set them off
really high.
And I'd be like, "Great, I'll be
back in three hours."
[ Laughter ]
Joke, but not a joke, really.
That was his world.
But then I think with "Dune,"
I think he was not prepared
for the emotional ride
that he went through.
He was sitting next to me --
It was my second screening.
I'd asked for another screening
because I really wanted to see
it with him before going on
the whole big world tour.
And I thought he was going to be
most excited about
the big Jason Momoa sequences,
and not to push Jason Momoa
down -- he's fantastic --
but my son was so excited about
the Hans Zimmer score
that he'd, like, every second
grab my hand and go,
"So beautiful."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Really?
Dude, come on. Shape up."
[ Laughter ]
-It's very funny to think of
anybody having to choose
between Jason Momoa
and Hans Zimmer.
I feel like that's not a choice
people are making that often.
-Not "rock/hard place," is it?
-[ Laughs ]
Jason Momoa and Dave Bautista
were on our show
talking about -- obviously,
you did a great many
location shoots
for a film of this scope.
Was there a place that you
particularly were drawn to?
-What was Momoa drawn to?
Did he tell you?
-It was very hard to understand
either of them.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, right.
I was just going to say wherever
Jason Momoa goes, I go.
You know?
-Yeah, exactly.
-So his location.
No, I -- Abu Dhabi,
Wadi Rum was amazing.
I mean, the desert. There is
something -- Have you been?
Have you been to the desert?
-I've never been, no.
-You haven't?
-No. Well, had you been
before you were in "Dune"?
[ Laughter ]
-No. I know.
I literally just thought,
"What a weird comment."
[ Laughter ]
No. No, Seth. That is true.
However, there is something
about being so small
in that enormous landscape
that is very, very humbling.
And people like us
need that sometimes.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So I would see Jason Momoa
on a hill,
and Timothee would be
on the other hill,
and we'd just sit there.
-Often when my wife and I
are arguing, she will say,
"You need to go to Abu Dhabi..."
[ Laughter ]
"...and get your ego in check."
-She will now.
-Yeah. "You need to go sit
on a hill in Abu Dhabi."
-Or actually, you know what,
Seth, can I tell you?
-Yeah.
-I'm going off piece.
-Great.
-I was in Wadi Rum.
And I was going in one of
those 4x4s, going up and down
the sand dunes on my day off.
Obviously, I didn't do that.
I haven't done any of that.
I didn't sign any papers.
But all of a sudden the guy
basically goes,
"Oh, my God, look at the stone."
And I thought,
"Sure, that's a big stone."
And he goes,
"That's where Matt Damon sat
when he did 'The Martian.'"
And I thought, "No!
I don't want to know that."
[ Laughter ]
"That just kills it for me.
That's a tiny rock, man."
-Yeah, you're like,
"This is the most amazing piece
of nature I've ever seen."
They're like,
"Nope, you're on a movie set."
[ Laughter ]
-"No. You're on a movie set."
Been here.
-Even people who have seen
the trailer would know
how terrifying the sandworms
in this film are.
But I hear sweethearts
to work with.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh, they're beautiful.
I have them in my contract now.
Just humbling, you know,
harming, small.
[ Laughter ]
They are -- The worst thing is
I wish I had --
We had sex names for everything.
Obviously I can't tell you.
But the ornithopters
were horny throppers.
[ Laughter ]
I can't remember
the sandworm names.
I think we should move on.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I think collectively
everybody agrees
that's the right thing to do.
[ Laughter ]
-Or not. Or not.
-Next time you have to share
all of them.
Hey, thank you so much.
Congrats again on
the news of the sequel,
and we look forward
to seeing you next time.
-I'll see you.
Thank you for having me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Dune" is in theaters and IMAX
and on HBO Max now.